voilà un nouveau rebondissement de
taille dans la sphère loana la jeune
femme hospitalisée depuis la semaine
dernière vient de prendre la parole pour
désigner sylvie ortega son ancien ami
comme présumé auteur d'une tentative
d'homicide contre elle la semaine
dernière sur notre plateau sylvie ortega
faisait déjà face à eric breier amis
proches de loana qui reprochait à la
jeune femme de lui avoir fourni de la
drogue
sylvie m'a donné un peu trop de
médicaments ortega a assuré n'avoir
donné qu'un xanax à loana pour qu'elle
se calme
l'ex-star du lot a depuis pris la parole
depuis la clinique où elle se trouve
je suis en clinique psychiatrique
enfermé dans une chambre blanche sans
télé depuis lundi à regarder le plafond
à cause de la dose massive de
médicaments tu m'as donné sylvie pour me
faire crever ils m'ont sorti du coma au
bout de quelques heures
des accusations qui font froid dans le
dos alors loana va-t-elle porter plainte
contre son amie sylvie earth égard ce
soir eryl prayer est de retour sur notre
plateau pour faire toute la lumière sur
cette affaire et on aura la version de
sévères dégâts devant voilà je vous le
dis parce que c'est aujourd'hui eryl
merci d'être avec nous la semaine
dernière sur notre plateau vous aviez lu
un sms de loana dans lequel elle pointé
la responsabilité de son ami agent de
sylvie dans son hospitalisation elle
disait juste qu'elle lui avait donné des
calmants mais l accuser personne en
direct dans tes pump et sylvie avait
répondu en affirmant qu'il n'y avait pas
c'est qu'un seul calmant un xanax à sa
demande
depuis lohan a été hospitalisée elle
s'est rétabli mais nous a enregistré sa
première réaction vous verrez en
exclusivité dans un instant mais sur son
compte facebook airs il vous avez
partagé un message qui aurait donc été
écrit par loana tout un feu dans lequel
elle évoque justement cette prise de
médicaments alors je vais dire ce
message après on va en parler
voilà loana m'a demandé de faire suivre
merci de partager au maximum ce message
c'est celui ci je suis en clinique
psychiatrique enfermé dans une chambre
blanche sans télé depuis lundi à
regarder le plafond à cause de la dose
massive de médicaments que matt stone &
cie vie pour me faire crever ils m'ont
sorti du coma au bout de quelques heures
ils m'ont mis ici pensant que j'avais
voulu faire une tentative de suicide
ils ont enfin compris que j'avais juste
demandé un calmant basique et qu'on
avait voulu me faire bien pire et pâle
inverse un cauchemar alors entre le fait
d'avoir failli crever être enfermé
depuis cinq
voilà en clinique psychiatrique est
prise pour une folle ça m'a fait
beaucoup croient mois loana airs il déjà
on va voir la vidéo loana dans un
instant vous êtes tombés des nues quand
vous avez eu ce message
oui parce que moi j'ai fait à la maison
j'avais tout préparé pour le tournage du
lendemain cette fois le tournage d'un
homme est basse et à la maison en fait
on des continue le tournage sur son
document clairement terre les guillaume
genton ouest et est d'ailleurs très
heureuse de faire ça et moi j'avais tout
préparé et le lendemain à l'équipe du
tournage m'a prévenu en disant qu'elle
était partie voilà aux urgences parce
qu'il ya eu un malaise et le
surlendemain
loana m'a envoyé un message où justement
elle me disait que si lui avait donné
des médicaments en surdose de
médicaments quoi alors guillaume genton
un mode sur leurs relations pendant le
tournage sylvie et loana faut savoir que
si leurs dégâts donc c'est le se
présente comme l'ami et l'agent de loana
sarko a réduit alors je me permets elle
se présente je me permets un loana m'a
dit de bien faire passer le message
ortega n'est absolument pas
l'agent de loana elle s'auto proclame
l'agent de loana loana m'a bien dit il
faut qu'elle arrête de dire à tout le
monde qu'ils avaient mon âge ans elle
n'est absolument pas mon agent je n'ai
jamais signé de contrat d'agent avec
elle a pourtant elle
aujourd'hui elle compte annoncer les
noms mais la réalité ça je peux vous le
dire il aux attaquants lyonnais signent
des contrats silure pega signe aussi des
contrats non rémunérés c'est une réalité
oui mais ce que je vous dis c'est que
elle n'a pas de contrat d'agent avait la
corniche je vous ai juste qu'elle se
présente comme son ami mais et hérite
jusqu'à ce qui s'est passé parce que
loana et simonet qu'est venue il ya
quelques semaines
si elle était très très proche si
viennois vraiment les venues d'ailleurs
séduit la prison doit être ouvert qu'est
ce qui s'est passé depuis lost qu'est ce
qui s'est passé s'est passé que la lui a
fallu une hausse de médicaments qui
alors qu'elle a failli en mourir donc
donc effectivement en plus en plus vous
le saviez ça vous que vous vous méfier
de sibur tega vois dans la presse un
rapport à ludovic le fils de celle là
oui oui effectivement oui comme a dit
benjamin castaldi
elle a quand même pas mal de casseroles
au cul alors juste eric qu'est ce
qu'elle lui a donné comme les calmants à
à loana je sais pas je me rappelais plus
des xanax le golden axe c'est quoi alors
0,25 de xanax dosé à 0,25 apparemment il
ya d'autres trucs aussi les voiliers ont
touché j'ai pas le gpra le cocktail en
tête de xana de temesta apparemment
c'est ce qu'aurait dit voilà loana
tenace de temesta quoi deuxième vague qc
- un café une claque son cul et on
rigole pas avec ça stéphane ccg grave
parce que là la loi n'a enfin le plus
grave est passé 1 je dirais les sorties
à midi on a mangé une lasagne au bord de
la piscine
elle a très très bien volé alors juste
non mais elle va mieux loin de là mais
c'est vrai qu'on a une vidéo utilise de
loana oui qui s'explique donc pour la
première fois depuis le gros souci qu'a
lieu la semaine dernière l'a choisi tp
pour s'expliquer forcément et c'est bien
elle qui a demandé à éric de transmettre
le message en question
regarde écoute et bmp c'est loana je
tenais à vous dire que les messages que
vous avez vu ce week-end ce sont bien
les miens c'est bien moi qui les ai
écrits c'est eric qui a transmis
communaux transmis à la vidéo parce que
j'avais pas internet
donc voilà c'est un peu mon plusieurs
voyageurs alors ah la la
déjà au format elle a le sourire et ça
c'est bien elle est hyper important
ensuite à la cus donc sylvie ortega de
lui avoir volé des choses regarde par
contre je tenais à rajouter à la tension
de sylvie que ma valise et étrangement
vides ils manquent de mes bijoux à vars
aux as et barda um que tu aimais tant
jusqu'à mi slip
j'en ai même plus une j'ai plus de
culotte plus de fer à friser plus de
bijoux les plus rien dans ma valise
la réal évident valises vie
étrangement et tu étais 7 kg était à
côté de moi dans la chambre d'hôtel
je vais porter plainte aussi pour vol de
tous mes bijoux quand il m'a appris dans
ma valise alors c'est vrai qu'on sache
là il ya eu un changement de cap pour
loana incroyable on verra s'il ya une
prise de conscience dans les derniers
jours de loana par rapport à sylvie
ortega moi j'ai retracé le parcours je
sais qui et les a mises en contact
c'était en septembre dernier c'est un
certain nicolas je vais donner que ça
fait combien de tonnes auxquelles ce
qu'elles se connaissent septembre pas
plus nicolas c'est le garçon qu'on avait
vu dans le documentaire voilà quelques
années j'ai été voir à cannes n'a pas là
et non c'est un autre tout ça c'est un
autre nom et non celle tant le fret de
celle période ainsi qu'il a ainsi lancé
un autre
ok elle ne se connaissaient j'ai un
sonore ou un loan a dit silver tegan et
qu'une copine de soirée et puis en
septembre par ce jeune homme que j'ai
rencontré loana est entré dans la vie de
sylvie ortega et c'est vrai que
maintenant il faut le dire on l'a déjà
un petit la dernière fois elle est
entrée dans la vie de loana pour
manipuler loana prendre de l'argent sur
le dos de loana est sans doute au début
avec l'accord de loana la maintenir sous
dépendance médicamenteuse donc loana
aujourd'hui sont rencontrés il ya une
manipulation de la part de sylvie ortega
qui est entré dans la vie de cette jeune
femme et c'est ce et j'ai trouvé voilà
d'après tous les témoins que j'ai eu ce
week-end il ya vraiment une organisation
de la part de alors on a notre extrait
de loana on passe tout de suite à la
dernière partie des miches
et loana a fait une mise au point sur
son overdose puisque l'histoire on va
venir avec l'ona avait pris jeu du ghb
c'est ce que vous nous aviez dit
guillaume genton la veille de son
hospitalisation et que s'il dit
justement lui avait administré des
médicaments pour essayer de la soigner
ces sales histoires aux passés pour la
vienne elle a fait une crise suite à des
drogues qu'elle aurait consommé et
sylvie effectivement lui aurait donné
des médicaments suite à cette crise
c'est vrai c'est ce qui s'est passé elle
a fait fort c'est parce que dit luan à
regarder ensuite de dire que je fais une
overdose ghb est rejetée à vous préciser
que je n'ai pas pris de drogue et que je
les analyse pour le projet non ça a été
à la fois de cause de médicaments que
j'ai eu ce coma de plusieurs heures qui
aurait pu me coûter la vie après comment
est-ce que je les ai pris moi je n'avais
pas d'ordonnancé n'avait pas de
médicaments je les avais oubliés à la
maison je n'ai pas pris de drogue du
bape et d'alcool forcément c'est bien
quelqu'un qui me les a données
maintenant j'ai plus personne et je vais
porter plomb peuvent plainte pour
diffamation parce que je n'ai pas pris
de drogue ce jour là et ce sont des
médicaments qui m'ont mis dans le coma
alors eryl loana là elle a l'air
vraiment déterminé oui par la plainte
contre silvio et aegas elle a vraiment
comme comme vous disiez la brume ans
réagit là elle a compris l a compris que
quoi que c'était une mauvaise que
c'était pas une bonne personne les airs
16 mois je vais parler de choses que
j'ai vues pour le coup elle est
physiquement présente avec elle sur le
tournage elle s'entendait très bien il
ya une chose qui est énervé un peu les
équipes de tournage qu'elle faisait tout
le temps des story quel film est tout le
temps qu'elle se filmer tout temps avec
loana et de là à dire qu'elle est on va
la tuer c'est vrai qu'il ya un
retournement de situation au départ des
classiques ubu ortega c'est que elle
voulait rentrer dans tournage elle
voulait se montrer dans tournage
oui par exemple le lendemain vous deviez
venir tourner à la maison et sylvie
artega avait dit à guillaume
oui bah je vais venir je vais faire
comme si je passais au lavandou comme ça
ça va me permettre de rentrer dans le
tournage et loana lui a dit mme hégo que
tu vas foot chérie tu ne connais pas ta
rien à [ __ ] ici quoi il ya une nuance
entre être un agent qui veut peut-être
un peu se mettre en avant
gagner de l'argent mais comme le font
tous les agents et vouloir tuer
quelqu'un c'est juste ça y est comme une
énorme différence et c'est vrai qu'on en
apparence elle s'entendait très bien
vous pouvez pas dire le contraire
depuis le début non mais vous dites
qu'elle va très bien
excusez moi mais la vidéo je vois je ne
vois pas quelqu'un qui va très bien je
vois quelqu'un en détresse
très lucide obama ne va pas faire un 400
m c'est sûr certes monsieur mais quand
elle est venue sur ce plateau ici elle
n'arrêtait pas de nous dire qu'elle
allait très bien et moi je voyais
quelqu'un qui allait pas bien du tout et
en fait tous ces événements récents
prouvent qu'elle ne va pas bien parce
qu'à d'abord aller toujours entouré de
personnes très nuisibles très dur
maintenant non mépris maintenant mais la
dernière fois nous a dit c'est fini
elle est venue encore il ya quelques
temps c'est fini plus jamais des gens
mauvais autour de moi tout à la fois en
fait une sorte de spirale comme ça où à
chaque fois je te moment c'est à ça que
nicolas va veiller et en oui mais sauf
que malgré tout j'ai toujours du mal à
la croire et moi j'ai envie de la croire
parce que je la trouve extrêmement
touchante mais quand elle nous dit je ne
chante pas drogue view nous dit autre
chose quand elle dit je suis bipolaire
et je me soigne avec ça je me suis
renseigné on ne se soigne pas avec eux
avec ce qu'elle a dit l'autre jour de la
bipolarité mombelli ce que je veux dire
je trouve que malgré tout elle a été
tellement un rat de laboratoire un
cobaye de la télé réalité que j'ai
l'impression aujourd'hui que nous on
nourrit régulièrement avec une pièce le
jukebox de loana et que ça me fait
toujours plus de mal est ce que vous
comprenez pas du tout à fait complet
enfin je suis un peu en décalage par
rapport à tout ça le moi j'ai connu
lohan à l'époque lou benjamin tu la sors
vainqueur de secret story et toy story
pardon et l a été quand même et même toi
je suis sûr que ça a surpris elle a
monté des chaleurs descendu les champs
elysées remonter on en a parlé à la fois
simple et c'était un phénomène
incroyable
malheureusement je pense qu'elles
courent derrière encore aujourd'hui
inconsciemment parce que sa vie
d'artiste lui manque éperdument mais
très sincèrement vous êtes son ami
profit vrai assez sauvages de ma rue
oui ça fait plus de dix ans qu'on se
connaît maintenant accords interdisent
et demi le faire des vidéos bah oui
interdisez lui de se montrer elle aime
ça interdisez lui si vous êtes vous lui
interdisez elle nous montre une image
d'elle pardon je la connais pas adele a
dû raconter pitois une pitoyable et qui
est aux anti thèse de la bimbo entre
guillemets qu'on avait d'elle et ça se
reconstruire loi n'a alors oui mais
cassure ou construisent et qui a bien
après cas là ce que j'ai vu comme vidéo
je n'ai pas pu la regarder et manger
je suis malaise de la regarder on la
voit en parler avec la bouche pâteuse
des mini-jeux l'aller fatigue parfois
mais voulait mais si vous êtes son ami
caché là je vois la cache là si vous
l'aimez d'accord ok voilà et c'est
vraiment je cachais la bombe ont discuté
avec elle non non disent je n'ai pas
vous êtes sur la me cacher là mais enfin
les majors de maxime est la vraie
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire aujourd'hui pour que loana ligne
il ya une réalité dans la vie de loana
c'est qu'elle n'a plus d'argent en fait
elle est fauchée elle a dit il y aurait
la charge eurobonds c'est une somme pour
vie humaine un loyer qui est très cher
elle va se retrouver à la rue
donc concrètement qu'est ce qu'elle va
faire elle va aller travailler au
supermarché elle en est incapable
elle a besoin d'argent elle a envie elle
est attirée par la lumière je pense me
tromper en disant c'est le dis tout le
temps il est aujourd'hui ben faire ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle est en train de
faire ses retombées des documentaires
c'est déjà une source de revenus pour
elle parce qu'elle est payé pour faire
ces documentaires
concrètement et le soutien-gorge et
socialement comment vous faites
aujourd'hui pour aider loana est bon on
marque on en reparlera des verts plus
rien le de haller bancaire pea si
brillant pour le pour le faire avec une
bienveillance mais elle est l epa
bienveillante pour elle même juste juste
vous avez vu que vendredi bfm tv a fait
une grosse gaffe et allonger la mort de
luan a par erreur sur le site web de la
chaîne qui a publié nécrologie vous avez
vu ça au paba l'ennemi je les verrais
bien fait ça ils vont perdre au près
serré l'équipe tv fait ça avec votre
père quand on y est on tombé partie de
la famille stéphane tapis pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent
c'est comment comprendre il ya eu le
monde il ya eu au monde et l'équipe et
dès qu'ils avaient annoncé votre papa
ouais et cd way comment vous qu'est-ce
que vous avez vous aviez vous leur en
avait parlé bah ouais enfin l'équipe tv
il ya un des rédacteurs qui m'a appelé
pour s'excuser julie d'aller se faire en
sorte d'accord voilà tu t'excuses mais
derrière mbc des erreurs de prompteur on
le prend en compte derrière un prompteur
il ya une personne et cette pauvre
petite conteuse ou ce compteur et il ya
quelqu'un qui lui dis bien à faut donc
voilà d'accord mais c'est
ces airs il loana vous allez vous en
occuper maintenant vous allez être à
fond avec elle maintenant elle va être à
cannes dans le sud donc effectivement
jeudi elle va être caché la wii lui va
pas vous lasser juste demain on sait
qu'à l'intérieur
silver tegam et silver tegan nous a
demandé un droit de réponse et vous
savez que mon télévision doit donner on
est obligé voilà donc s'il y sera avec
nous demain pour donner son droit de
réponse aux accusations de loana et de
son entourage mans